PRESIDENTRUMP'S TOP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS TEXTED EACH OTHER
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S GLARING
SILENCE ON THE TRAGIC DEATH OF
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER BRIAN
SICKNICK WHO SUCCUMB TO HIS
INJURIES THE NIGHT OF JANUARY
7th.
MURTAUGH SAID ALSO [ BLEEP ] NOT
TO HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THE DEATH
OF THE CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER.
IT WAS RESPONDED, THAT'S EN
ENRAGING TO ME.
EVERYTHING HE SAID ABOUT
SUPPORTING LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS A
LIE.
>> NEW TEXTS REVEALED BY THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE LAST NIGHT
REVEALED HOW TRUMP'S OWN
CAMPAIGN AIDES WERE SHOCKED AND
UPSET BY HIS REFUSAL TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DEATH OF CAPITOL
POLICE OFFICER BRIAN SICKNICK.
CAMPAIGN MANAGER -- OR CAMPAIGN
SPOKESMAN TOLD A COLLEAGUE HE
BELIEVED TRUMP WASN'T MENTIONING
SICKNICK BECAUSE HE DID, QUOTE,
HE WOULD BE IMPLICITLY FAULTING
THE MOB.
THEY TOOK A MOMENT TO THANK
OFFICER SICKNICK AND THE OTHER
FIRST RESPONDERS FROM THAT DAY.
>> WE'RE HONORED TO BE JOINED
TONIGHT BY POLICE AND FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO BRAVELY PROTECTED
US ON JANUARY 6th.
YOUR CHARACTER AND COURAGE GIVE
US HOPE THAT DEMOCRACY CAN AND
SHOULD PREVAIL, EVEN IN THE FACE
OF A VIOLENT INSURRECTION.
>> JOINING US NOW ARE THE FAMILY
MEMBERS OF OFFICER SICKNICK, HIS
BROTHERS KEN AND CRAIG, SICKNICK
AND HIS BROTHER GLADYS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR GETTING UP
WITH US THIS MORNING TO TALK
ABOUT THIS.
I IMAGINE HEARING THOSE TEXT
MESSAGES OF WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING IN REALTIME BEHIND THE
SCENES IS PRETTY FRUSTRATING.
>> IT WAS.
IT WAS -- I THOUGHT IT WOULD GET
EASIER AFTER ALMOST TWO YEARS OF
THIS, BUT IT'S GETTING HARDER
AND HARDER, ESPECIALLY AFTER YOU
LEARN NEW THINGS THAT ARE COMING
OUT.
>> IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY
FRUSTRATING.
THE PRESIDENT IS SUPPOSED TO
REPRESENT THE COUNTRY AND WE'RE
SO FAR BEEN OVERALL A PRETTY
GOOD WORLD EXAMPLE OF HOW TO RUN
THINGS AND WITH THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION THAT WENT RIGHT
OUT THE WINDOW.
>> AND YOU'VE LISTENED TO
THOSE -- THE LAWMAKERS LAST
NIGHT TALK -- AND HIS OWN STAFF
TESTIFY THAT HE HAD OPPORTUNITY
AFTER OPPORTUNITY TO CALL OFF
THE VIOLENCE, BUT HE DIDN'T WANT
TO DO SO.
>> WELL, DO YOU KNOW WHAT, I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THIS A LITTLE BIT
THAT WE'RE -- WE ARE FOCUSING IN
ON THE FACT THAT HE JUST DIDN'T
ACT AT ALL FOR THREE HOURS,
WHICH IS JUST ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG
TIME I'M ANGRY FROM SEEING IT
AGAIN AND JUST REALIZING THAT HE
DID NOTHING, BUT OVERALL WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON THE FACT
THAT HE STARTED THIS WHOLE THING
TO BEGIN WITH.
SO, YEAH, HE IS AT FAULT FOR NOT
STOPPING T BUT HE IS REALLY AT
FAULT FOR RILING UP THE CROWDS
AND GETTING HIS -- I MEAN,
SYCOPHANTS FOLLOWING WHATEVER
WORD HE SAID, THEY WERE ON THEIR
PHONES, WE SAW VIDEO OF THEM
LOOKING AT THEIR TEXT MESSAGES
FOR THEIR NEXT COMMAND TO, YOU
KNOW, CALL OFF -- TO DO WHATEVER
THEY NEEDED TO DO.
SO, YOU KNOW, I WOULD LIKE TO
FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT HE'S
RESPONSIBLE IT HAPPENING IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
>> AND, KEN, WHAT DID YOU MAKE
OF THE TESTIMONY FROM SARAH
MATTHEWS WHO WAS A DEPUTY PRESS
SECRETARY, TALKING ABOUT THE
INTERNAL STRUGGLE TO GET HIM TO
SAY SOMETHING, BUT SAYING HE DID
NOT WANT TO USE THE WORD "PEACE"
OR "PEACEFUL" IN HIS MESSAGE?
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
IT'S OBVIOUS TO ME THAT HIS
EXISTENCE IN THE WHITE HOUSE HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH HELPING THE
COUNTRY, HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH,
YOU KNOW, LOOKING OUT FOR THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE COUNTRY, IT
WAS LOOKING OUT FOR HIM.
IT WAS LOOKING OUT FOR -- TO
MAKE SURE HE IS IN POWER, TO
MAKE SURE HE CAN CONTROL
EVERYTHING AND -- AND THE
SILENCE OF THE THREE HOURS, IT
COULD HAVE BEEN HIM STUCK
DECIDING, YOU KNOW, WHETHER TO
SAY SOMETHING, BUT ULTIMATELY IT
WAS -- IT WAS HIM COVERING HIS
REAR END AND HIM MAKING SURE
THAT HE WAS IN POWER AND THAT HE
COULD NOT ADMIT TO ANYTHING
HAPPENING.
AND I JUST -- I CAN'T COMPREHEND
HIM NOT DOING A THING TO STOP
THAT.
HE KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON, WE
SAW IN THE TESTIMONY MINUTES
AFTER -- AFTER HIS LITTLE RALLY.
>> AND, CRAIG AND GLADYS, THERE
WAS THIS MOMENT THAT REALLY
STOOD OUT TO ME LAST NIGHT WHERE
YOU SAW ERIC HERSCHMANN WHO WAS
THIS ATTORNEY INSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE AT THE TIME, HE TALKED
ABOUT WHAT THAT DAY WAS LIKE,
THE CHAOS INSIDE THE WEST WING
AND HE TALKED ABOUT HOW DRAINED
THEY WERE BY THE TIME TRUMP DID
FINALLY PUT OUT THAT STATEMENT
FROM THE ROSE GARDEN, BUT THE
ATTORNEY FROM THE COMMITTEE WHO
WAS INTERVIEWING THEM NOTED THAT
WHEN THEY WERE KIND OF CALLING
IT A DAY, TALKING ABOUT HOW
DRAINED THEY WERE, THAT WAS
STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
AFTERNOON WHEN RIOTERS WERE
STILL THERE AT THE CAPITOL AND
THESE OFFICERS, INCLUDING BRIAN
AND THESE PEOPLE WERE STILL IN
THE MIDDLE OF DEALING WITH
RESPONDING TO THIS.
>> YEAH, THAT REALLY BOTHERED ME
A LOT.
YOU KNOW, THEY WENT HOME TO
THEIR FAMILIES, THEY HAD DINNER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR LITTLE
KIDS -- WHAT DID THEY TELL THEIR
LITTLE KIDS?
AND WHAT REALLY BOTHERS ME ABOUT
THIS WHOLE THING IS THAT ALL THE
PEOPLE AROUND TRUMP, THEY --
THEY STAYED WITH HIM FOR FOUR
YEARS AND LET THIS HAPPEN.
SO THEY'RE CULPABLE, TOO, BIG
TIME, IN MY EYES ANYWAY.
>> IT'S ASTONISHING HE DECIDED
HE HAD A ROUGH TIME AND IT WAS
TIME TO GO TO BED, MEANWHILE,
PEOPLE WERE STILL BEING INJURED,
SOME OF THEM QUITE SEVERELY,
MANY OF THEM WERE JUST TRYING TO
DO THEIR JOB AND SUPPORT THE
COUNTRY AND THE OATH THAT THEY
SWORE, WHICH APPARENTLY TRUMP
IGNORED.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS JUST
UNBELIEVABLE THAT THIS CAN
HAPPEN IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO WATCH THEM
LAY OUT, TOO, JUST EACH CRUCIAL
MOMENT OF WHAT HAPPENED AND
REALLY WHAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
KEN, CRAIG, GLADYS, YOU GUYS
HAVE BEEN THROUGH A LOT AND
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU
CAME ON TO TALK ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
I'M GLAD THE COMMITTEE WENT OUT
OF THEIR WAY TO NOTE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM BRIAN AND
EVERYTHING AND TO HONOR HIM.
AND WE'RE VERY SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS, BUT WE DO THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING US.